In Israel,
just to give a general explanation in
Israel,
we have,
according to the law,
we have to give everything that's
rewrite about military and intelligence
issues to the military censorship.
This book was submitted to military
censorship when it came back,
I counted 750 deletions,
a and a tedious negotiation started with
them
and we submitted some appears to supreme
court in most cases.
One of them is the case of an in Israeli
businessman ex officer with the idea of
a hero of the Yom Kippor,
October 72,
the war who became a businessman and
cynically crudely and viciously sold
chemical warfare to Iran.
The fact that this was not caught by
Mozart in time and the whole affair a
were banned by military censorship.
I appeal to Supreme Court and won.
And there's a chapter in a book called
the termite file because the whole
operation was called him the termite,
uh,
describing the operation.
In some cases we reach compromise.
One of them was very funny.
I think there was.
There's a,
there's a chapter called the second
coming of Hezbollah that starts with an
interview with a prominent figure
dealing with his Bible in which he says
in 50 years when they opened the secret
files,
people in Israel would be amazed to how
poor was the human penetration of
Israeli intelligence into Hezbollah.
When,
when people would read the secret files
that would be shocked and sad to see
that Masada looked far less,
eh,
like James Bond and far more like
inspector clouseau.
And then he asked me,
do you know how many real agent did
Israel have in the ranks of Hisbala?
Like true ranks,
not in the sympathizers.
Nordion outside circles his troops,
and he left some fingers of his right
arm.
Now military censorship took everything
out.
We appealed against it and the outcome
was a compromise in which they permitted
to publish everything.
And it's in the book,
except for the exact number of fingers
that he lifted.
So if you read it,
you'll see that it's somewhere between
one and five because it's only his right
arm and fingers were chopped in previous
operations.
Uh,
but there's no exact number.
I think it's ridiculous,
but yet we had to reach some sort of a
compromise.
I would say this,
the bottom line is the 95 percent of
this book is new information and I think
that after all the knowledge of the
reader of what's going on in that
clandestine war between Israel and the
United States and one hand in Iran was
not severely damaged by this.
Of.